was all confused like I was I thought I
saw something that wasn't happening body
cam video shows the aftermath of a
bloody crime scene at the home of a
Wisconsin woman who's now in prison for
stabbing her ex-boyfriend more than a
dozen times with a pair of scissors
22-year-old Morgan Lun was sentenced in
November for stabbing her ex and the
father of her child 19 times while he
was sleeping on the couch back in
February in body cam footage obtained by
long crime officers arrived to the scene
to find the victim lying on the couch
begging for help as Morgan stands near
him covered in blood right is it just
the three of you
okay ambulance is downstairs over the
officer then pulls Morgan to the side to
get more information from her as the
victim continues pleading for help have
you got shoes or something you can oh
they're downstairs
okay they're coming we go we got to go
we got to go I can't see yep Medics are
coming is this your stuff yeah do you
have an ID in
here um no it's in the
car Ean no
[Music]
come oh my
God
what is your
name it's unclear when but during this
time emergency crews seemingly tend to
Morgan's ex-boyfriend's injuries
portions of the audio were redacted from
the video but Morgan can be seen visibly
distraught while begging the officer to
let her speak with her
father Morgan can you tell me a little
bit more about no
[Music]
no and why is that do you feel
no why why are you saying no I don't
understand what you're reacting to right
now are you just scared about the
situation or do you not want to talk to
me I want my dad I want my dad to come
here okay I understand that but you're
you're an adult so I need you to make
your own decision about whether
to tell you what what do I need to tell
you the questions that I was asking what
kind she then explains to the officer
she thought she saw a mysterious figure
when she attacked her ex-boyfriend while
he slept I was I was sleeping and then I
don't know I was like half
away I BR out here every morning beer
uhhuh and I mean I seen the same thing
before I never done anything like
that you have seen the same thing before
okay have you ever had any kind of
medical treatment or anything like that
have you seen a doctor psychologist
counselor anything I didn't to embarrass
to talk to anybody okay went back to
that I didn't I didn't get much sleep
last night I don't know why okay and
then I finally fell
asleep and you and you what I finally
fell asleep and I was seeing all these
weird things I know it's blood all over
me
but you don't remember coming back out
but you do remember seeing
something I was like it was like in my
head though and it wasn't
real that's when I was like what is
going on I didn't know what
happening can you describe for me what
you
saw I was
like I don't know it was like something
black you scissors
no still there and then he was
like I felt
like I don't know
what but it was like then I was like is
he attacking the thing that I saw I
don't know I was all confused like I was
I thought I saw something that wasn't
happening shortly after another officer
takes photos of Morgan whose hands
clothes legs and feet appear to be
covered in blood then the officer
continues his questioning where Morgan
explained she had been suffering from
hallucinations and experiencing mental
health issues adding she had an outof
body experience during the incident you
usually see the same
thing and I feel like somebody else it
feels like it's not even
me if you had to physically
describe what you were seeing like big
or small black or white white gray blue
whatever like a like a
blob like a blob like a black blob a
blob but like a figure
okay I don't
know I something
I do you see a dark figure but it
doesn't look like a person am I
understanding that
right it's just sort of
the the shape I can hear I hear I can
hear
him
who and then I came out and I saw
something like over
him so I don't know like what was like
real and what's not real what I don't
know if I was
[Music]
dreaming but the other experiences that
you've had have been when you were awake
yeah we're like half awake okay right
before you went to bed or right after
you woke up both both but it's usually
never do that I would never do that to
him but it's usually that same sort of
dark
figure that you see yeah but it's like
it's like it's there something it's
something in my head it's not
like I don't know how to explain it
but when you see it your heart beats
really fast and you you feel
afraid okay I just feel like like
something's taking over me like I don't
know and now it's like everything's
normal and that happens every
time what is going on the Mental Health
Institute and I feel like ever since I
started working there like cuz I talk to
the patients a lot and I feel like it's
just like getting in my
head and i' I've talked to people at
work about it without like saying
anything like I've been
like is it like do people ever get
affected by this and like have you ever
seen anybody that works here be affected
by it and they like all of them have
said that yeah like they've seen people
be affected by it or
like I don't know and I just feel like
something something just changed in me
since
then as Morgan continues to speak with
police another officer arrives on scene
to speak with Morgan's brother Ethan who
was staying the night at the couple's
home on the night of the stabbing and
called 911 Ethan while holding Morgan's
crying child tells the officer he was
sleeping when he heard Morgan and her ex
and what he thought was another verbal
argument I thought they were just
fighting like
normal and it starts getting loud loud
what the hell was he screaming back at
her it was kind of like
a I don't even know like get off me help
I and that was him saying that I don't
even remember and open the door they're
on top of each other what do you mean
they both were on top of each other he
was like on top of her trying to take
the knife out of or something I don't
know okay so okay how was she
positioned like when you say when he was
on top of her was he like straddling her
yeah he like had her wrist down and then
holding her wrist like straddling her
like
that okay and then was he bleeding
already at that time yeah where was he
bleeding where' you see his arm and
stuff and then had seen the
couch go over there I don't even know
she's that was like when it was ending
okay was she saying anything at this
time she's just freaking out I don't
know she's saying she doesn't know what
happened she that she was seeing stuff
having a dream or something and then
realized it was real okay does she
suffer from mental health I think since
she's had kid CU that's their kid yeah
and
then I just went R call the cops Ethan
goes on to tell the officer a similar
story to Morgan's she thought she saw
something in her head but Ethan also
revealed to police that Morgan and her
then boyfriend were experiencing a lot
of relationship issues and that fighting
between the two wasn't uncommon okay did
she say it might have been a dream or go
back into that yeah she was kind of
saying like she was like as I'm calling
you guys that she's dreaming or
something and then like uh seeing
something in her head I don't really
know and you Aon is this his bedroom
that's that's where he stays he doesn't
live here but he stays here yes
um and you said that she might have some
mental health issues since she's had a
kid explain to that have you seen a
change in behavior
um I think just a bit of
maybe postpartum depression maybe or but
you've seen a change in change in
personality
um maybe not a change in personality but
sit there she
uh you're not getting me a those are you
okay they got a a lot of relationship
problems okay so okay so this is this
fighting minus the actual injuries is
not uncommon no so they argue a lot yes
are they physical a lot no just verbal
arguments a lot yeah okay Ethan says he
never saw the actual stabbing only the
aftermath the officer later puts a pause
on questioning Ethan so he can tend to
Morgan and the victim's child who
continue to cry then the officer briefly
observed the scene noting just how
Bloody it was you got all this ladder
it's on a kid toy over here too
yeah I got meanwhile a frantic Morgan
continues speaking with police who
inform her she's under arrest and they
have to take her to the police
station I just can't even process this
minutes later she tearfully pleads with
officers asking what will happen next
you know what's going to happen we
genuinely what's most likely in this in
this we don't ever know be honest we
seen
before my dad worked for a prison for so
long and I work at the mental health in
I I've seen like things like this and I
I just want to know like what's most
likely going to happen to me I've been
doing this for 12 years and I've never
been in this situation before no so this
exact situation and each one is a little
bit different but this exact situation
what I will ask not to intervene is your
mom and dad are outside they're going to
take is it possible miles to C her at
the vehicle where
do anything they're just I just don't
want them to see her being are you okay
yeah I don't want okay um we'll just
walk with you and then go from there I
would just ask just don't don't really
talk or anything to them at this point
um we'll allow that later okay they can
come in and we we'll work with you as
the officers walk her to the squad car
Morgan can be heard crying asking her
father for help as he tries to figure
out what even happened shortly after
Morgan's placed in cuffs and taken to
the police station where her brother
Ethan is already in an interview room
and gave a written statement to police
before going over his account of what
happened with detectives so you guys all
kind of came home around the same time
yeah but I never saw them okay they in
their bedroom or yeah well I'm pretty
sure you s on the
couch sure do you know why he s going on
the couch or just because they're
arguing I'm guessing Okay so they're
arguing a lot then
or uh
I don't know I think they're just
breaking up or something but they only
argue
like I don't know
when something goes wrong I guess I
don't know okay do you know why they're
breaking up
or I don't think she feels like he's
treating her like right okay any issues
with uh her thoughts on how he's
treating the baby
not that I know
okay have you ever seen their
relationship get physical no
okay do anything to her physically
anything no so when they're arguing
they're just verbally arguing yeah how
often uh since you've been there has he
been sleeping on the
couch I
say I want I get the wrong time but prob
month or so something like that okay and
that's like all the time he's been
sleeping on the couch not just once here
I don't know if he occasionally goes and
sleeps in the room or something okay
Ethan tells the detective his sister has
been suffering from postpartum
depression since she had her child
nearly a year ago and the baby's 11
months old yeah she's almost one okay so
was she talking about that before before
the baby was born or while she was
pregnant or no I never really seen her
when she was pregnant but okay no not
that I know so after the baby was born
what was she talking about
just uh whenever be hanging out or
whatever meet her and her boyfriend and
like if she would get sad or something
she would bring it up
and I don't know just didn't know how to
do with it we didn't know she just
saying this or what
but she definitely start acting way
different can you kind of explain what
that what that acting was or
um it just like maybe her mood overall
and how she's going about her day and
not being as active
and just really showing your emotions I
guess so uh and I don't want to put
words in your mouth I'm just trying to
figure out what you're saying like is
she kind of a flat effect or is she
really emotional or what what is it that
you're
seeing
um it's like she'll be crying out of the
blue or something or yelling which is
just stuff I've never
seen stuff like that that's different
from when we lived with my mom in high
school and stuff she wasn't like that
okay
so kind of out of nowhere she just
started crying has she gone to the
doctor for her I not sure if she's ever
gone to a doctor but she's told me and
my family members about it okay did she
talk about seeing images or things or
anything I don't think so
no just today she was saying she was
seeing something I'd heard her when when
I was in the spare bedroom after all the
cops and stuff I heard talking to one of
the cops saying
she okay but when I was on the phone she
was saying I don't know what was going
on I didn't mean it I think I was
dreaming like I didn't have control just
something along the lines of that
okay have you seen or heard them talk
about breaking up or what that status is
yeah I mean they're uh they definitely
breaking up like I think their uh leas
is up in want to say June first maybe
and then both trying get
apartment okay so they've basically
broken up but they're together at that
house because co-parenting right now
something okay and how long has that
been going
on that they've basically broken up and
decided they're going their separate
ways uh I mean it's hard to tell because
they're so on and off but i' say
definitely a solid month that they've
been distant and while Ethan says he saw
something in Morgan's hand when she
attacked her boyfriend at the time he
couldn't narrow down what the weapon was
as he initially thought it was a butter
knife Ethan wraps up his interview
telling police he was in shock that the
incident happened adding he's never seen
that amount of blood before and I'm sure
you've seen some blood in hockey right
not that much though no probably not
that much but at this point Morgan is
now in a police interrogation herself
being read her Miranda Rights after the
detective asked Morgan if she wants a
lawyer present unsure what to do Morgan
again asked the detective if she can
call her father who advises on the phone
to hold tight you're not yourself you're
not you're not yourself you didn't do
this on
purpose I did it on
purpose was he
sleeping I don't know I was like I was
like half
asleep I
know you you having a dream yeah I was
like like I was having a dream and then
I was like half
awake to the living room yeah and then I
I woke up again and I was like half
asleep and I was like seeing things but
I was like I don't know there's like
something in my head that like makes me
not who I
am did your doctor give you any
medicine no
no can I come there as her like she has
a representative with her can I come
there with her um sure if you want the
video then shows Morgan in the police
interview room for about half an hour
waiting for her father to arrive once he
arrives he explains to the officer while
Morgan has been suffering from mental
health issues and postpartum nothing
this violent had ever happened before
how how much do you know about what's
happened this morning not too much
um my son called me a couple times I
didn't answer and I I called him back I
think he was probably calling you guys
and stuff but he said she was like
sleeping and she had a bad dream and she
said she didn't know where she was and
stuff and she know what was going
on um she's been having like she's had
postpartum depression since she had the
baby and like my wife was a social
worker for years and like program
director and stuff and she kept saying
like she's got she's having like mental
health issues and I it would I would
bounce around it with her but I didn't
want to like accuse her of having like
mental problem and stuff so I would I
never pushed it far enough to like make
her go get help okay
um but as far as today goes like he
Ethan said and I saw her too it was like
she wasn't even it seemed like she
wasn't even there like she's never like
grabbed a weapon and done anything like
that before and
um she's just been like I know she's
been crying out of a blue like she'll
just start falling for like nothing's
going on and she'll just start falling
like she said when I say she said weird
things to me she'll she'll say weird
things to me and I don't I don't say
anything I just let it go cuz I know
she's having like mental issues so I
don't want to say the wrong thing what
do you mean by weird things just weird
like she'll
not just talking about or weird stuff
like I don't know
like I can't think of specific example
just like this weird not not like weird
crazy stuff but
like talking about stuff that we weren't
talking about or something and like it's
just like she's different she's way
different you know I'm pissed at myself
because we wanted her to get a good job
and everything and now she's like now
that this happened I'm thinking I told
my wife how stupid are we like we
encouraged her to go work at the mental
health facility because my wife was a
program director there for a long time
okay and we thought that's a great job
it's a state job I ran a prison for a
living so we're like we know it's a good
job we never I never thought for one
second about like the stuff that she was
going to be reading and hearing about
people she was going to be talking to
when she's having her own issues already
it was stupid I never even thought about
that but I can tell you right now she's
never grabbed a weapon and done anything
I was shocked when he called me it just
it doesn't make any
sense or what happened I don't exactly
know what happened but I just don't it
doesn't make any sense but I know I can
tell you 100,000% she's been totally
different since she had her baby and
she's never gotten any help for it the
body cam video ends with the officer
telling Morgan her father had gotten a
hold of an attorney she was ultimately
arrested for the violent slashing and at
the time charged with attempted first
deegree intentional homicide according
to court documents Morgan's ex-boyfriend
who survived the incident told police
she had been physically abusive
throughout the duration of their
relationship even threatening him in the
past he said he didn't know why she
stabbed him especially in front of their
daughter Morgan initially pleaded Not
Guilty by reason of insanity back in
March but later pleaded no contest to
aggravated battery and second degree
endangering safety in November a
Wisconsin judge sentenced her to seven
years behind bars plus 5 years of
extended super for vision reporting for
long crime I'm Elizabeth Milner